the real problem is our sort of referral  mechanisms are a mess and the rwanda  scheme is  um  sort of eye-wateringly mad and um  callous  you know we're exhibiting a callousness  as a  in government that i don't think  reflects  the soul of this country and the nature  of the people in this country i really  don't  i understand that that  uh  you know a lot of refugees will be  thinking well it's all you know all the  ukrainians are white and this kind of  welcome wasn't given to syrian refugees  when the same sort of thing was  happening in aleppo and all that and i  understand that too but at the same time  there's been a huge compassionate  opening of of british people